Zachary is with us in San Antonio Texas
a Zachary how are you good Dave how are
you think you're taking my call sure
what's up so I am currently 21 years old
I Oh
$7,200 left on a car that I bought in
2017 and I have about 12,000 dollars
saved up I was I started listening
probably I don't know three four months
ago and I just wanted to call in and say
you know is that something I should take
out of the $12,000 savings and just pay
it off now so how much have you been
listening over the last month I've been
five days a week just while I work
okay then you know what I'm going to
tell you don't you I I'm knowing what
you're going to tell me but I just I
wanted to be sure but I also wanted to
ask this in consideration to it that's
the only thing that I have on my credit
as credit history so should I continue
paying it off to get more credit history
or should I just pay it off all in one
month son okay here's how we've led more
people out of debt and into everyday
millionaire status than anybody else we
have figured out that the shortest path
to wealth is to not use up your most
powerful wealth building tool which is
called your income so when you don't
have payments when you stay out of debt
it is one of the key data points towards
building wealth so I don't borrow money
and for 25 years that we have taught
people not to borrow money and to get
out of debt as fast as they can and the
reason is what I just said because it's
the shortest path to wealth that's
simple okay now once we've established
that then we say okay what is building
credit well building credit is I'm going
to go into debt and pay it on time so
that I have a better score with the
credit bureau so that I can go into debt
and pay it on time so that I can have a
better score with the credit bureau so
that I can go into debt
and pay it on time so that I can have it
that's building your credit that's how
it works right right sounds a little
like a dog chasing its tail okay and so
if you if you if you stipulate in this
conversation that the shortest path to
wealth is to avoid debt then going into
debt in order to have the opportunity to
go into debt in order to have the
opportunity to go into debt is not the
shortest path to wealth as a matter of
fact it'd be just plain dumb and so I
don't I don't teach people to build
their credit my credit rip my credit
your score is zero okay
well I just I didn't know if that would
affect me in the future on buying a
house and it's honestly I'm ready to pay
it off today and beat that free by the
end of the day but what are my next
steps after that well then let's start
building an emergency fund and then
build up a big hairy downpayment on your
house and I assume you're renting an
apartment I actually stay with family I
only pay about three hundred bucks a
month on rent
perfect okay well they made you may have
to when you go to get a mortgage if you
have zero credit now you don't have zero
credit you've got a car that will
continue to show on there as having been
paid off but I assume you paid it on
time
have you not oh yeah I'm like I had on
the payments okay then it's going to
show up the time that you've had the
debt is going to show on your credit so
you do have a credit score you do have a
credit report but if you don't have
enough then the mortgage company will
have to do what's called manual
underwriting
which means they will just say okay
verify your job verify your down payment
and they can have the people that you're
living with write a letter and say he's
paid us 300 dollars a month to rent for
this many years or months or whatever it
is and that's enough to get a mortgage
at the same interest rate as people with
a high credit score it's called manual
underwriting and if you if your mortgage
company doesn't know how to do it folks
check with churchill mortgage they
actually know how to do it a lot of the
mortgage companies have gotten so dumbed
down that they don't they're not allowed
to think anymore and they just look at
them a monkey looking at the credit
score yeah the number is big enough who
the numbers not big enough whatever it
is right and so that's the one time if
you're borrowing money that you're gonna
not have a credit score you have to have
a work around the rest of the time
you're paying cash for cars trips
furniture whatever it is you're gonna do
you're gonna pay cash for it no building
the credit score and you know the
problem with the credit score is there's
no middle ground
you either got to go borrow $150,000
over the next four years and pay it back
in a bunch of little gotcha debts and
kicking kicks in the butt and kicks on
the teeth and then you'll have an eight
hundred credit score or you have zero
credit score like I do and you gotta
just aside which way you want to live
living in the middle with a 650 credit
score is a dumb idea that'll kill you
you get nothing then you've got nothing
from either side of this equation so
good question thank you for joining us
open phones at Triple Eight eight two
five five two two five justin on twitter
is in the same Camp David know you
suggest canceling credit cards doesn't
hurt your credit rating yes it does or
is this just another ploy by credit card
companies to get you to keep them no it
it hurts your credit because you're not
you don't have the account open anymore
and it's systemic it doesn't hurt it
like you're like paying late it doesn't
it's not a black mark but the way your
credit score works the algorithm the the
mathematical algorithm that builds your
FICO score is based on your consistent
and constant interaction paying them
money and if you quit paying them money
than being the bank's consistently
constantly then you're not gonna have a
high score so if you have one account
that's open versus twenty accounts
that's open you know that and perfectly
paid you're gonna have a lower score so
yeah closing up your credit card
accounts does damage your score with the
goal being for your score to disappear
because you have no open accounts of any
kind no outstanding balances of any kind
nothing where you're interfacing with
the grid
and then you get what I get for 28 years
I've at a zero score indeterminable
actually sent many mail who want to make
sure that you're not feeling poorly are
you sick have you died kind of a threat
I think
doing just fine thank you very much and
just not giving you people a bunch of
money anymore
[Music]